a great person to look to is is tim
dillon or schultz
and how you know you can you can see
what tim is making now
i'll go so far as to say i don't even
think it's possible to make that money
in tv unless you're a massive name on a
massive hit and
good luck with going for that i mean
that's like three or four people who are
gonna get lucky and get that so
there you go look at the money tim's
making and if you don't know what that
is
it's a lot of money and it's all
all due to his podcast it's all because
of his podcast so
those are the guys to look up to now
schultz rogan
uh you know uh tim tiger belly oh you
know bobby lee
all the guys are doing that and even
some of the youtube guys and meme
guys and you know though you know even
tank sinatra i mean those guys are
making a living so if your goal is to
make it in entertainment
that's what you have to really consider
nowadays and you guys know that i mean
this is all young kids know that better
than old kids
but it's actually doing it i mean you
know we're like okay yeah i need to
be online a lot i need to be posting
sketches i need voices or characters but
then it's like
i mean even me you know i'm 11 years in
and last year i released my own comedy
special i was
booked on a tour like i was going to be
a touring headliner
and then covet hits and i was like i
guess i gotta do social media
and then now now like half the time i
just looking at my phone like
i don't even know what i'm doing like
like what am i going to do right now you
know
well yeah a new a new job has emerged
in the field of comedy and that's the
that's the uh
the tech guy the the guy you got to get
yourself
a guy who's a guy who can edit or
you become that guy and all that stuff
but you need a camera guy you need
you need uh you know this and there's a
lot of people out there who are terrible
at comedy
um some of you aren't sociopaths and
have a little self-awareness
i recommend to you guys you have a
little epiphany and you say hey
i'm not funny at all i love comedy
uh i'm lucky enough to live in this era
where you know what let me learn how to
do
all that other [ __ ] and let me join
someone who is funny
and will become a team and make content
who was the other guy on your team you
said you had the producer and who's the
other
yeah then i got i got uh i got my boy
drew
um and he uh you know he has aspirations
to become a comedian i
good luck with daddy you know i hope he
does that but he also knows how to do
all the tech stuff so
he's sort of uh our intern now that uh
works with us so there's two of them
jessie's
my producer and drew is the intern and
it's those two guys
you know they bang everything out they
make the clips they they record the
podcast they produce it they direct it
i sit down and i just [ __ ] yell like
a madman that's my job
is to to try to tell jokes to feed my
daughter's face
if you love comedy as much as we do here
at hot breath
click the subscribe button to join the
hot breath verse and then watch more
videos to get even more comedy tips
you